what's the best part of the writing
process for you that is a a profoundly
good question
um
i i think when you
find
that synergy
between
your characters and the plot
and again things are starting to roll
and
and it could be in the outline phase too
i've had plenty of experiences with you
know having that breakthrough where
you're like oh right
this is
this is where i need to go um
[Music]
it's not i don't think it's necessarily
one thing it could be you know you write
it
you write a terrific scene or a great
chapter and
you're just like yeah
then of course you know you could always
go back the next day and think what the
hell did i write
but
that doesn't happen as much i think when
you feel when you feel like you really
pulled out and you really expressed
yourself in a way that or had the
characters express themselves in a way
that
you know resonates with you
um
i again i think i think it it's it can
be any it's
it can be anything again from
you know
really thinking up a cool plot point
to
really getting that lock that log line
down we were like oh this is you know
i'm on with this and i'm one of those
people who's um
i know uh william broyles jr who is a
terrific screenwriter he's one of the
best
you know he always i remember reading an
interview with him years ago saying
never be satisfied
and
i agree i i'm not always satisfied i
always want to um
uh
i always think i can do things better
i'm a perfectionist i always want to
continue to mine and if somebody says to
me this we can do that i'm like great
let's let's do it let's mine this let's
let's keep let's dig
um
so
so for me i i think when you know um
the the the
the time where i really feel
where i love with the process that i
love is i think it's just it's the
discovery
discovery of again
your character where they're going um
and it could be you know uh the
characters and
is in trouble and how do we get them or
her out of it what's a creative way of
doing it and always thinking
you know again i hate the expression
outside the box but thinking outside the
box
coming with a new way
and
a new twist and and how that you know
being inventive
and when that works and it's working on
the page and you or you think it's
working on the page and you're like oh
that's cool
and it opens up and it's that it's those
those psychological
breakthroughs in a sense in in regard to
the creative process
so when you start to see that wow these
dots are connecting this is actually
working
it's great it's great it really is it's
um
yeah it gives you it it gives you a you
know confidence and
you you just feel it you know it's it
buoys your spirit a little bit like i
said the next day you could go back and
you're like
okay i got through this now you know
that's why i get it's good to have an
outline but even in having the outline
and knowing you know how do you start up
especially in you know writing you know
writing that next scene or writing the
next chapter you're still staring at a
blank page you have an idea of where you
want to go but then it's a matter of you
know really inventing that and it's
that's something else that's
exhilarating but also daunting at the
same time without a doubt
what's the fastest you've ever written a
full screenplay and did that screenplay
get made fastest
uh i actually i i wrote take back pretty
quickly
the first draft
was probably a couple of weeks
after it outlined it
it was pretty quick
um it took a little while to get made
and it went through subsequently through
a number of drafts but
yeah i probably wrote in about three
weeks
three to four weeks maybe um no not even
four weeks i think it was like three
weeks three weeks yeah i had it i had it
pretty much locked in but again that was
the first draft
and um that's the other thing it's um
uh you know
writing is rewriting is rewriting is
rewriting so you know
what i always enjoy actually and i
should you know back this up is that
putting the script down is that putting
that primer down is
is fun
but i really enjoy going back and going
back into it
and
reworking it
and reworking it and reworking it
because i think if you've laid down a
good blueprint
and you have a good bare bones
you know what you're basically
transferring from the outline
to that to that script
um
i think that you know going back and
reworking it and making and polishing it
and and really exploring it even more
that's when the real work is done
and that i think is what's most
rewarding for me personally is the
rewriting process
for sure
have you ever fallen in love with a
character not one that you'd written but
another one where you felt that the
person was real you know we were talking
about earlier about salinger and the
letters and this book that i read and
these people related so much to holden
caulfield and they just right they felt
he was so real um sure
did you ever feel that for a character
whether a book uh i don't say falling in
love but i i've had some characters that
i've been really taken by um
santiago and the old man in the sea
um
nelson demille who's a contemporary
mystery detective write novels he's sold
very well he wrote the general's
daughter and a few other that have been
made into movies um
he has a character a plum island john
cory's character who i adore i think
he's
and demille's
always like
his written uh some some you know he's
john corey is wonderfully entertaining
and funny and witty and acerbic and
and uh empathetic and i love i love his
cat i love that character
um
off the top of my head um
i really uh recently um i'm like a lot
of other people read where the crawdads
sing
um
and um
the the young little girl who grew up
and just
just sheer empathy for her and her story
again i don't i didn't fall in love but
just loved
where
what happened and where
she went
um where they took where the writer took
her and and uh
just being so involved and rooting for
her so fiercely i could say that about
jay gatsby
so mysterious and and i was always
fascinated more by jay gatsby and i like
i loved catcher in the rye but there was
always something just that allure about
jay gatsby
um
and um
yeah and again i've
you know again my memories coming up
short but um
yeah i don't know i've i've
been invested heavily i don't know that
i've ever
completely fell in love with
um
with a character but heavily invested in
rooting for yeah and adoring
characters for sure and i know i gave
you novels i didn't give you necessarily
screenplays but um
you know uh
i think you know one of one of the
reasons that i am that i am still french
connection is one of my favorite films
is the dynamic between
gene hackman and roy scheider popeye
doyle and sunny um uh
i forgot uh his last name um it was
cloudy
was the nickname popeye and cloudy uh
obviously was their buddy dynamic
but um also it was again i
you know these were new yorkers like
myself
and they had that attitude and they they
really
i just always took a shine to them i
thought they were they were terrific and
and really loved them and loved how
loved their dynamic and
uh and the movie in general did you like
serpaco yeah another great one uh pacino
again new york yeah new york and and uh
his uh his intensity in that for sure
and in a lot of his films
you